[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
I think us as a country
owes Richard Nixon our deepest
most genuine apologies
for thinking that you couldn't get any
more corrupt as the President of the
United States or a former president
United are just a human being in general
oh my god of course there's
[__] tapes
you know a lot of people are making a
lot of bones about the tapes and how
he's admitting to crimes on the tapes I
don't I don't I don't think uh there's
anything in the tapes admitting what the
transcripts didn't already say
that he's like yeah I could have
classified it but I didn't and I can't
because it's still secret but I'm still
gonna wave it around and show it to you
the thing that I think is the the most
trumpian about all of it
is that he's doing this seemingly and my
my take on it the hearing the tone in
his voice and how he's saying it and the
mood in the room that you can gather
from the audio is that he's doing this
to try to impress the women in the room
he's like yeah isn't this cool and it's
so cool these are tap Secrets what the
[__] are you kidding me oh man I mean
it's not surprising
that he's a [__] criminal he doesn't
give any [__] about anybody but himself
he doesn't care about our national
security he doesn't really give a [__]
about all that stupid [__] he said about
Hillary and the emails and the
confidential information he didn't give
a [__] about any of that stuff he
doesn't care about our our military the
dod the CIA our assets our intelligent
services are the human beings that
operate it he doesn't give a [__] about
you and your safety as far as National
Security he only cared about one thing
in that room in that moment is for those
women to think he was [__] impressive
it's always 100
every single [__] time count on it
about him every [__] time
don't get it twisted don't [__] lie
to yourself
it's about him
always never about anyone else he wanted
to get a little mud for his turtle and
he thought that he could impress these
women in that room
it's what it was
and you can say oh well he was trying to
get retribution on Millie come on [__]
out of here like he gives a [__] about
Mark milley I just done told you he
doesn't give a [__] about anybody but
himself
he could care less
it was to impress the people who were in
front of him always
that they thought he was the greatest
ever in the history of ever ever
and to stroke his little ego and maybe
his mushroom
[__] insanity
and then
and then projecting and
oh my God as if we're not on to this
[__] every time he posts on true
social what he says and what he rants
about especially when it's in all caps
is always
in confession projection and confession
every single time and when he says Jack
Smith leaked these tapes
it's because he did
it was him I'd hate to break it to you I
really do and the media is like we're
not really sure where these came from we
can't we can't really identify the
source of leaves
listen
it was him
every single time it's him he knows
these the transcripts are already out in
the open
they're in the indictment right
and the transcripts alone are
incriminating otherwise otherwise the
special counsel wouldn't have put it in
the indictment that material evidence
to make sure that the courts knew that
they have material evidence
now
here's the thing we just went through a
part of the discovery process of the
non-classified information guess what
would probably be
guess what would probably be in that
information and I would imagine that if
there's an attorney who who helped him
do this they're in big [__] trouble
too
and I don't know if you heard did you
hear Jack Smith is gonna take a a work
trip to Georgia
oh
apparently he's gonna go see the
Secretary of State Brad Pitt said Burger
smoker Burger something like that
yeah he's gonna go see Brad
ranthisberger
in Georgia and probably I don't know
interview him I'm sure I'm sure that
it's not about I'm sure that this has
nothing to do with the fake elector
scheme or the telephone calls that Brad
rathersberger had to record with Donald
Trump in it kind of funny
around this month
this mother cord themselves and
conversations with them and it kind of
funny it's almost like everyone's
wearing a wire
I would be would you go in the same room
as this [__] without recording
hails to the no I'd have I'd have a hot
mic on the whole time not not not to
[__] with him I don't want to be
implicated in any [__] crime
and I guess the question is with this
tape
let CNN uh release yesterday which again
the only thing that's really new about
this
is the tone that he had and you can hear
the papers that he's shuffling around
and you can damn well tell that yes he's
at Bedminster he took the [__] boxes
for Mar-A-Lago and he moved them
to Bedminster and he's sitting there
showing people who are not able to see
this information or even know it exists
folks it's not even that they can't look
at this [__]
they're not even supposed to know that
this exists
[__] wrap your head around that
this [__] not only is showing
people documents that they're not
supposed to see he's telling them [__]
that he's not supposed to tell them
it has nothing to do with the documents
in and of itself other than the dude is
mishandling classified information
documents papers folders boxes of them
and out of his [__] yappy little trap
because he's trying to impress the women
in front of him
what else could it be you tell me go
listen to the tape and tell me that he's
not trying to he's not trying to impress
the women that are in the room
so he can so he may or may not be able
to get a little you know what I mean oh
yeah
a little mud for his turtle
get the [__] out of here you know that's
what he's doing in the in the [__] oh
her here Tony he he was just trying to
make a point about Mark milley to to a
reporter get the [__] out of here
come on
you really think Donald Trump needs
evidence to say anything disparaging
about anybody have you ever watched this
[__] at all
come on he doesn't need documents to
wave around and to show someone
classified information to make a point
when he's disparaging someone who he
hired and act like he admired at one
point
[__] out of here
you you're not convincing me in nothing
when you're saying that type of [__] he
was doing it to impress the women in the
room because he is a [__] skeezy
bastard
that's what it is that's what it that's
what the tape is
I mean I would love I would love to have
a tape of Donald Trump sitting down with
a bunch of Saudis and selling I don't
know two billion dollars worth of
Secrets
I would love to have that tape I I don't
even know that it that that it that it
does or doesn't exist I know that it's a
damn good possibility
that a conversation existed like that
and it's probably if it happened it's a
damn good possibility it was recorded
I mean I'd love to have that
tape out there um interwebs oh [__] it'd
be great
but that's not what this is this is
clear what this is
and just because he's trying to impress
women in the room because he's a [__]
skeezy little [__]
doesn't mean it's not crime
and that's the craziest part is this
this is just a tip of the [__]
evidence Discovery Iceberg that's why
they that's why Trump oh leaked this
[__] that's why he got it out
there in the open because it's just the
tip of the [__] evidence iceberg
he's gonna have waterfalls waterfalls of
smoking guns here
I mean there's [__] people lined up
around the block to to testify against
him as Witnesses in this case
and in the January 6 case we see the
Secret Service
we see Mark Meadows flipping on him
Jack Smith is going to Georgia
come on
I guess the most surprising are really
it's not surprising it's not surprising
at this point we really don't have two
political parties in this country we
don't the Republican party is [__]
dead they're just kicking around a dead
[__] body at this point
I would imagine in 15 20 years we don't
have a Republican party in that they're
still Republicans being elected in some
State houses there's a few members of
Congress that still put an R next to
their name because they're they're
outright Nazis
but within 15 20 years I really don't
think the Republican party is is part of
our two-party system in that they're a
major political party in this country
because right now they're really not
the only reason why they're still
Clinging On the power is because they
have their cult
and these people are [__] absolute
deranged deluded and delusional
I mean they're going they're going to
nominate him
the media needs to stop with this
[__] [__] about DeSantis listen
if DeSantis it isn't rising in your
stupid little poles he's finished
he's done
if this if this [__] isn't gonna tank
Trump nothing will dummies
what don't you understand about cults
I've been telling you this
DeSantis should have waited his turn
maybe we would have a Republican party
later on in the decades to come
but they really did think that that the
Department of Justice Merrick Garland
and Jack Smith was gonna hand Donald
Trump his own rope and he was gonna hang
himself with it
but somehow someway they don't care that
he did
it's because it's a cult
they want to hate
they want to divide they want fascism
he allows them fascism in any shape or
form
you understand that right
it's not about his views or his
principles it's that he doesn't have
them
this tape [__] lays out that he
doesn't have principles
his his aimless Meandering trying to put
himself in a situation to impress a
couple people in the room
and not fully grasping what he's even
doing in the moment after he's been the
president of the United States
do you have any [__] idea
how serious [__] can get in a room with
the president United States with
classified information
with I don't know maybe plans to attack
a foreign country like Iran
do you know how [__] serious those
conversations would be
and hear this [__] is on audio
not even not even not even coupled to
the reality of how serious
the documents that he's waving around to
impress a couple a pair of tits in the
room because that's the way he'd use it
I don't care what you say what you think
this isn't about [__] selling secrets
on this tape
this isn't about him [__] showing
someone classified information
it it
lays out that Donald Trump has no
principle has no beliefs
he's a [__] meat suit for fascism
that's what they [__] love about him
the reason why they hate Ron DeSantis is
because one Rhonda santis is a goddamn
weirdo
and he's not a very good [__] meat
suit for their style of fascism which is
anything they want
anything it could be anything yeah
yesterday it was Garth Brooks with Bud
Light in a bar
today it's naked people running around
at a festival in [__] Seattle that's
been a festival for 34 [__] years you
dumb [__] this [__] just didn't
happen
our our next oh coming in the next five
minutes coming in the next five minutes
they're gonna cut up a [__] audio
tape of Joe Biden that proves he's a
criminal and why he should be locked
away and we should impeach him
[__] out of here man that's why they
love him
they love him because he lets them be
the worst [__] versions of themselves
because he is the worst version of a
human being
the worst the [__] worst
and really honestly who should be on
trial here is his [__] parents
you know you don't you know what I'm I'm
told I've told you this before you ever
been in the grocery store seen that
little [__] you know what I'm talking
about that [__] that's whining
and crying because he can't get a fifth
box of cereal and he's laying on the
floor yelling and screaming cursing at
his mom kicking her the dad going hey oh
man uh don't don't do that I don't I
don't want to have to punish you
you just want to go over and pick the
kid up spank him on his ass
yeah I know you can't spank kids no more
but you want to spank that [__]
don't you
don't you I mean you know you don't want
to but yeah boy your brain can't help
but go there
I can't believe what happened
70 years ago in the Trump household
we're [__] still paying the price
Jesus [__] Christ
but that's what the I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna play the audio tape for you
I'm gonna play it for you of course I am
well how couldn't we play this piece of
[__] gold
and I'm gonna point out exactly why I
think it is the what I think it is
it's sad
it's it's it's disgusting
it's laughable
it's hilarious how smart they think he
is
oh my god when you when you listen to
this tape
and you go and you see the defenses of
this they're like oh well hey he was
just pointing to a stack of newspapers
the people in the room that are on the
audio recording
have confirmed
what he was waving around
why do you think they put it as material
evidence
in the indictment
and for you to to to act like Tom fitton
is smart and you're gonna take advice
from him are you [__] [__] me
this is this is like trying to take
Health advice from RFK Jr
who will stick anything in his body but
a vaccine well he is vaccinated but he's
gonna tell you not to when he's
vaccinated and he's the hoot God knows
what kind of roids that motherfucker's
on
we live in a wild time
the wild
time
to be [__] alive
also I don't know if you this kind of
got buried in the news did you know
oh [__] there's emails that's right
there's [__] emails
there's emails from Trump staff campaign
staff that they knew that he lost
they acknowledged that he lost but they
were still gonna grift
his supporters anyways that's um what
hey can you grab the uh federal statute
book I think that's wire fraud
I I can't even [__] imagine
oh what
we have to do in this country to prove
to the eight ten twelve percent of the
dummies
of how stupid it is for them to just
tie him around their ankle as an anchor
and throw themselves
off the coast in New Zealand to go look
at the Titanic I have no idea what we
have to do to convince them I don't know
if it's gonna be a hundred felonies
I don't know if it's gonna be 200
felonies
I don't know I mean eventually a federal
judge I I can't see how a [__]
federal judge is gonna say wait wait
okay wait you're you're you're being
charged and indicted on 34 felonies in
in the Manhattan Manhattan District in
the state of New York your your business
has already been convicted of 17
felonies
in the state of New York your CFO went
to Rikers
you got 37 felonies because of the
Espionage Act in Florida right
God knows if Jack Smith can bring
indictments in New Jersey because this
[__] had documents at Bedminster
I don't know exactly how that works I'm
not a [__] attorney
Jack Smith is on his way to Georgia and
going to [__] D and probably has a
grand jury in D.C
so why is he going to get indicted in
Georgia on how many God knows how many
counts in DC on God knows how many
counts
and you think a federal judge is going
to go you know what
yeah go ahead yeah you keep your
passport no no big deal hey go ahead go
ahead have fun on your golf course
I'm telling you what folks
I don't know if you know this but
average average Americans out there if
they were charged with over a hundred
felonies there would be no bail
at all
not even a [__] number not a not a
loan that they can afford it but there
wouldn't even be a [__] number no
judge would afford bail for someone who
has over a hundred felony counts against
them and they can't stop criming
they can't stop they don't they don't
know how to stop
a federal judge would not grant that
bail they would lock them the [__] up
now
even Laura Loomer today he's like
two-tier Justice she literally tweeted
his little rant and said two-tier
justice system
it's like yeah
you're a big man that [__] is
not being protected by his privileged
little tear of Justice anymore
but he is he is being protected any
other one of us any of us committed
these many felonies had this type of
evidence against us we would be sitting
our ass in a cell
100 percent
and if and I don't know if uh
demogoladites out there understand how
pissed off the country is gonna get
when they keep watching him over and
over and over again get indicted on
dozens and dozens of charges including
God knows what for wire fraud for
[__] for [__] duping them and
stealing their money
this country is gonna get pissed off
about a two-tier justice system that is
protecting him and let him run free
now do they lock him up do they not I
don't know we'll [__] see what
happens and when more indictments come
because they're coming folks
they're coming
they're not stopping with this
I would imagine that that eventually
Arizona Pennsylvania Michigan and even
Wisconsin could play into this whole
[__] elector scheme
and not just Trump and his allies but
state state lawmakers former State
lawmakers State party members will be
charged and convicted
of Fraud and trying to overturn our
election
they keep wanting to rehash 2020 but by
God there's going to come a point where
they don't want to talk about 2020
anymore
because of how much [__] crime there
was Jesus Christ there's already like 2
000 people that are charged
with a violent insurrection
to try to overturn our vote
but we must stay engaged because I'm
telling you it doesn't matter if he's
out running around yelling and screaming
saying stupid [__] threatening
prosecutors threatening Witnesses just
outright admitting to his crimes right
out in the open or if he's locked in a
jail cell he's gonna be their guy
I hate to tell you this I'm telling you
if this ain't moving poles they're
little precious these pundits poles and
the media's polls Ain't Nothing Gonna
Move It and I don't know if you notice
Ron DeSantis is dumping gazillions of
dollars into his campaign and he still
ain't getting anybody to [__] show up
for him
he's getting endorsements no one gives a
[__] as soon as he gets endorsement you
know what Maga says well there's a
[__] rhino
they've always got the answer don't they
they've always got it just like he does
and that's the point
the cognitive dissidents
is astounding
the dung and Kruger effect
is absolutely [__] fantastic with
these people it's fantastical
and it ain't going away anytime soon
so strap in engage in your democracy get
ready because it's gonna be a [__] of a
fight because we can't just fight for
the top of the ticket we have to fight
all the way down
this morning the Supreme Court hands
hands manga another slap in the face
we headed them off in 2022.
we made sure there was a democracy
Safety Net in Pennsylvania Arizona
Michigan and Wisconsin
that was one of their plans to overturn
the next election and overturn our
democracy this morning the Supreme Court
in a 6-3 decision told them no you can't
do that
oh oh oh you were planning on
overturning election in 2024 no you
can't do that
it's not how it's gonna work here [__]
but we can't stop just because we have
allies just because these decisions and
the democracy is going our way we cannot
stop
I don't know if you noticed this but the
foolishness isn't gonna stop
the delusion is not gonna stop the lies
are not gonna stop They're Gonna Keep
peppering Us with them
so it is our job
to yell to scream to engage in our
democracy to aim our strategic outrage
it's time right now
right now to get in the fight
trust me democracy is worth it
coming up on the 4th of July speaking of
democracy and Independence the Fourth of
July
is coming up upon us and I have an
announcement to make we are going to
take off for the Fourth of July I think
we're going to take a short little
vacation I know you folks are going to
be out there uh celebrating with your
family and friends
I hope you have a safe weekend this
weekend this holiday weekend and into
early next week we're going to take off
Monday Tuesday Wednesday of next week
so we will only be on the air Thursday
and Friday oh I mean we got to do
bonehead of the week how could we skip
bonehead of the week so next week Monday
Tuesday Wednesday while I have all of
you here I want to let you know that we
will not be on the air
it will be vacation time time to
barbecue time to recharge the old
batteries
so I want you guys to have a safe
holiday weekend we will keep announcing
this so you know that Monday Tuesday
Wednesday next week we will not have a
show
but we we look forward to coming back on
Thursday and Friday next week and keep
pounding away at these fascist [__]
right here on YouTube don't forget to
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
for two full hours we got a lot of new
listeners holy [__] the audience is
growing more and more people are coming
every single day
to listen to me yell and scream to give
you cathartic release
against these [__] idiots don't
forget to follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels POD at the Tony Michaels and at
I am Gabe Sanchez also if you want to
watch it on Facebook you can watch it
over there if you're on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels just go to at the Tony
Michaels on Facebook also follow us on
Twitch it's free to follow us on Twitch
go to twitch.tv Tony Michaels and do me
a favor if you're out there and you've
linked your Amazon Prime account to your
Twitch account go resubscribe to our
Twitch account with your Prime account
don't forget you got to re-subscribe
every month so all of you who have
subscribed before thank you re-subscribe
again we've had several that new
subscriptions just just in the last well
here just in the last minute six minutes
the mob bother
uh let's see who else do we have Jets B6
uh we had mama bird robin our our
moderator over there has resubscribed
for six months in a row thank you Robin
we appreciate you being over there on
Twitch
and if you want to know how to tie your
Prime account to Twitch just go to the
Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com and the directions are
there it's like the fourth link down
and it says link Amazon and twitch you
click that our great um moderator the
mighty librarian did directions there
online I've linked them there so you can
figure out it's really simple really
easy directions on how to link your
Prime account to a Twitch account and
give us that one free subscription you
get with Amazon we get a couple dollars
every month it's a great way for you to
give monetary support to the show
without costing you a single dime Penny
Nickel whatever
they only give us a couple bucks a month
but it's free if you're a prime
subscribers to go to the Tony
michaels.com why you're on the Tony
michaels.com don't forget to to visit
the merch store
we got we still got pride month going on
we got the pride [__] em logo out there
if you use the promo code it's a big
secret now turn the volume up if you use
the promo code Pride the promo code
Pride at
store.dtonymichaels.com that's promo
code Pride at
store.the20michaels.com you get 15 off
your entire purchase the entire thing so
go to store not d20michaels.com use the
promo code pride get your pride package
over there fanny packs t-shirts tank top
stickers
go to
store.dtonyminkles.com we always
appreciate the support here on the show
it's Tuesday
and you know what that means it's tacos
but it's Texas Paul everyone don't go
anywhere we'll be right back with Texas
Paul right after this
we'll be right back mark
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thank you very
much over on Twitch re-subscribing with
your Prime account
it's very important if you want to uh
for us to get your couple bucks a month
from Amazon Prime if you tie your Prime
account to the Twitch account very
importantly you go over and re-subscribe
to the Twitch account with your Prime
account just go ahead and hit
re-subscribe it takes like I don't know
two seconds three seconds so thank you
for everyone who does that that is very
important to us that keeps us going here
on the Tony Michaels podcast it's a
really cool way for you guys to
monetarily support the show without it
costing you a single extra nickel I mean
you already pay for Amazon Prime and a
lot of people don't know that you get
that one free subscription on Twitch
with Amazon gaming with your Prime
account and and it's just a free way if
you link the two and again you go to the
Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com directions are like the
fourth link down and you guys can go
it's easy directions to link them and
then even if you need to create a Twitch
account and you can link the two it
gives us monetary support it's very
important here to keep us going speaking
of us I've got Gabe Sanchez and Texas
Paul in the wing should we bring him in
or should I just make him wait I don't
know what do you think does he just make
them wait I don't know I mean hell it's
you know it's only it's only 12 36 right
I mean
Texas fall is giving me the middle
finger maybe I will maybe I [__] will
make them wait then oh no I'm just
kidding uh Texas Paul Gabe Sanchez
welcome to the uh welcome to the
broadcast here yeah well don't ask me
brother I got I got a fresh banana bread
right out of the oven oh God damn man ah
now I am gonna kick you out of the
studio this is ridiculous
there's my banana bread I love banana
bread but is it banana nut bread or just
banana bread banana nut bread it's good
uh I love it I love me some nuts here's
here's the question though yeah okay can
you yeah
sit down and have only one slice no yeah
right it's one of those things where
it's like it's out there I might finish
the whole loaf oh yeah I used to I so so
I I live in Mennonite country right
there's a lot of midnight like country
stores and they'll make these they'll
make the the fresh uh banana bread and
they make some of those some of those
stores have some of the best [__]
banana bread on the planet no offense to
miss texball I'm sure hers hers is
fantastic but here's what I'll tell you
here's what I'll tell you I used to stop
and that's what I would eat for [__]
lunch
I would be like yeah I want me some
banana bread and I need great just stop
and just eat that for lunch that's all
I'd have I just take the I just tear it
up like a muffin and eat that [__] like
a muffin
it's a I mean it's it's it's truly
there's nothing better
than banana Texas Paul you've seen Tony
there's steam coming off of this brother
right now
listen all right I gotta go get
something I'll be back wow wow see you
later what do you put on your banana
bread you put you put butter spread on
it what do you put on it you don't need
it if it's cold I put butter if it's hot
out of the oven I eat it just a week I
don't need you don't need [__] on that
thing no I I I have mine thanks for
asking Tony uh the way
oh hey all right let's move on here
let's go to some news no I'm just
kidding how do you like your banana
bread just straight up man you don't put
butter on it no I have it how it was
intended to be it has everything that's
there warm even better if it's cold
totally fine no I'm I am I'm a big
banana fan and I grew up having that
like my grandma would make banana bread
and Angel uh angel food cake and pound
cake and all this stuff and I would
always at night just go down to the
kitchen
sneak his place [__] be getting
up in the morning be like wait a second
there's a [__] loaf of bread here
earlier yeah
I guess Texas Paul Texas Paul didn't
like our talk on banana he was like I
gotta I gotta I think he's having
problems I go down as a kid
and I'd slice that [__] you know and
then in the morning my Grandpa would be
like uh who who had more banana bread
than what we left last night and I'd be
like
um I don't know what the [__] you're
talking about you're like yeah yeah who
made all that [__] bananas
though there were there were on occasion
where I wouldn't say anything and then
like my mom or someone else would be
like oh I snuck a piece and I'm like oh
yes
you're like okay I'm in the clear I'm in
the car now I'm in the clear now all
right we got we got big banana back uh
here
uh sorry man I had to I had to click out
for a second my damn cat was going from
a banana bread I didn't want everybody
blame the cat I don't blame the cat I
don't blame him I don't blame him you
know we add a lot of people are saying
in the chat that uh Gabe is a big banana
fan and they're big banana fans too they
love bananas I mean there ain't nothing
better than a banana you know you know
what's funny so many different uses you
know it's regular Frozen whatever I
don't I don't even like bananas but I
love banana bread I know that's weird
but like I mean I'll eat a banana yeah
but I'm not like excited about bananas
you know what I mean oh I love it
something like you want a banana I'm
like hey I'm not that [__] hungry
bananas and peanut butter done amazing
banana peanut butter oatmeal banana
peanut butter sandwiches I mean just
banana peanut butter on its own like if
you're on the go you're like all right
I'll get like a little like scoop of
peanut butter I have manners in your
kitchen right now yes but I need to get
new ones because these are like they're
nearing the end and I haven't had any in
the last you know you know what's a good
idea for those bananas that are nearing
the end
banana bread I'm just saying no I know
there's a there's just I'm just saying
I'm just trying to I'm just trying to uh
I mean I will say that my partner
occasionally will be like did you buy
these bananas just so they would go bad
so I would make banana bread and I'm
like I plead the fifth
the same way blood the fifth when the
banana bread was missing in the morning
holy [__] did you did you guys see the
news did you see the news oh did you see
this I mean yes I'm assuming you're
talking about the news
yeah the only news yeah they're they're
banning a Coal Oven pizzas in New York
that's the one I'm done yeah that's the
one
did you see this [__] so apparently some
some [__] is wanting to ban Cole or
they're wanting to restrict the cold
pizza ovens and wood fire pizza ovens in
New York which is a bunch of horseshit
right and they're coming after our ovens
this is [__] dumb listen hey hey
liberals out there if you don't want
this to be a thing online stop doing
stupid [__] like trying to [__] get
rid of coal-fired and wood-fired ovens
for pizza right I mean I get that you
don't want people to heat buildings and
homes and you know have huge [__]
cold plants I get that but really you're
gonna go after the pizza fired Evans get
the [__] out of here with this nonsense
that's the dumbest [__] I've ever heard
you're just giving them [__] cannon
fodder but I can't believe that the
right Wing's like oh my god look New
York City won't have coal-fired pizza
you're not going to New York City you
[__] toothless redneck what the [__]
are you you're like oh New York City
that's a hell hole it's a [__] hell
hole but they got the greatest Pizza in
the world
all the same same people as we determine
is going to talk about the tapes didn't
you you guys thought I was gonna happen
well yeah yeah yeah
but I will say those are the same people
that are complaining about these
coal-fired pizzas right or any or of
ovens like anything of the sort where
they're not the the people who live
there they're not the demographic that
would be affected or impacted by it
these are the same people who want to
[__] and moan about Garth Brooks okay
right as a as a uh free market sets a
price has a concert has a partnership
says you guys can go [__] yourselves
because they're a bunch of [__]
again First Amendment facts over
feelings
and uh I don't [__] care about
whatever you guys say because they're
all bigots
those are the same people that are like
oh we gotta cancel boycott Garth Brooks
those are the ones that fall for the
dunning-kruger times right I think that
people are going to his concert in pain
anywhere from four hundred dollars to
nineteen hundred dollars to go boycott
Garth Brooks right that's so Texas so
Texas Paul where do you stand because I
I know this is important news to
everyone out there I mean the right
Wingers are acting like this is the only
thing in the news where do you stand on
Colin Wood Fired ovens
my God
you know if you're worried about all 12
Coal Fire ovens in New York City and you
think that's a problem
I mean you're an idiot that's where I
stand you're an idiot I mean there there
are problems that we're facing but that
this ain't one of them and quit giving
them things to talk about for Christ's
sake man yeah I mean sometimes I
actually think I really do I hate to go
all queuing on all conspiracy theory but
sometimes I actually think that these
are closeted right-wingers just saying
stupid [__] so that their Echo chamber
sound machine can pick it up and run
with it
well that's a good point because because
I want to get to this tape but it's not
the tape you think it's the um it's did
you finally find the P tape well
I mean I may I may have it here in the
storage cabinet no I well I'm sure Trump
has ears were not the tape that I'm
talking about is the one yesterday of
Joe Biden oh my God the Republicans are
like look he's admitting to Crime on
tape and he was clearly joking why give
you if you watch the the clip you would
know he's joking if you didn't like cut
it up uh uh Republicans you would know
that he was joking he said he was joking
he was joking before he's joking after I
mean this is [__] ridiculous but
Texas Paul just like the Wood-Fired and
coal-fired pizza ovens because
realistically what they're trying to do
in New York City is trying to reduce
emissions on those ovens not actually
getting rid of them they're just trying
to reduce emissions so they're trying to
get these people who have these ovens to
say Hey how do we be more responsible
about what we're doing right that's what
they're really doing
um but again it just gets out of control
here because yesterday we saw the
Republicans in the right wing when they
knew I think they knew that the Trump
tapes were gonna drop and we're going to
get to those so they preempted it with
this Joe Biden look he's admitting on
tape that he committed crimes uh our guy
won't be admitting on tape here in a
couple hours that he was doing crime on
tape what do you make of this Texas Pawn
am I just crazy because there was
Community notes on these tweets let me
pull them up while you're while you're
giving us your opinion on this Joe Biden
clip what do you think about this
outrage over this Joe Biden Cliff what
do you think
you know man I I don't mean to be a dud
on this but every time I see these right
Wingers lose their [__] I just I I just
I throw my hands up you know it's it's
it's it's like the the gas stoves
you know the the federal government
comes out and says hey you know what
we're building our houses pretty tight
now so if you got something that runs an
open flame in your house you probably
ought to get some fresh air you know I
mean it was it was that simple
Republicans they want to take your
stoves they're trying to ban your stoves
you know
it's always nonsense it's always made up
[__] I mean this world is tough
enough people this is why I say
Republicans cannot govern Republicans
cannot govern because they you know we
have real issues going look at Russia
man we've got a a a a geopolitical enemy
the only other real superpower in the
world is destabilizing wait wait wait
you saying we should focus on that you
know you're telling me there's news out
of Russia is that what you're saying
well let's see what Benny says about the
news in Russia let's hear let's hear
what he has to say about him Benji man
let's let's hear what Benji has to say
about the news in Russia I'm sure it's
just enlightening well well ladies and
gentlemen Joe Biden's going to New York
unfortunately he won't be able to pick
up a slice of pizza when he gets there
New York has canceled Pizza
are you [__] kidding me man that that
you know I wish this wasn't real but
it's [__] real well I'm signing off
I mean it's really as dumb as dog [__]
like you said Texas Paul like whatever
happens in Russia I mean when we can't
predict it we don't know because they
are so unstable and and it's such a [__]
show over there and when this is what
you have when you have authoritarians
and clip clip toxicities and also
oligarchies this is what happens
um when when one actually when one
oligarch begins to control more power
than another oligarch they now want to
centralize their power which seems to be
what is happening um but we don't know
what's gonna happen but it's gonna
infect the entire world whatever
whatever the outcome is it's gonna
affect the entire world
Texas ball
yeah
I agree with you I mean I agree
I want you to tell us yeah go ahead oh I
was just gonna say
um
look I know I I know I I know I know I
know I know I bring a lot of facts on
the show and I know yeah from you Tony
okay
how many restaurants uh
how many restaurants
do you think would be impacted by this
change okay I I would say it's at least
all of them probably probably and I bet
it's even in Florida that they're
affected by by laws in the city of New
York probably I mean I Gotta Give it to
Benji I mean it's oh sorry what I read
that wrong uh no it looks like it's
under a hundred restaurants in total
that would be impacted by such a policy
change
in New York but but but but but why
would they cancel Pizza why would they
outlaw Pizza Texas Paul why would they
do that
yeah they they wouldn't and and what
what Gabe's talking about is gonna you
know Democrats around the city so it's
not going to be hey tomorrow you got to
have your restaurant changed or we're
going to shut you down it's going to be
uh by 2027 you're going to need some
sort of filtration on your exhaust right
yeah I mean and it's not going to be
tomorrow I bet Gabe's tapping away right
now going to find out exactly when it
goes into because that guy's got the
facts man but I'm telling you it's
constantly this nonsense constantly
these distractions
it's all they have it's literally all
they have I mean can anybody else tell
me a position on any major issue that
Republicans have you know it's like down
here in Texas Tony I mean on the
libs on the lips that's their position
you know down here in Texas our roads
are [__] our schools are [__] our
electric grid is [__] but good good God
you know we've got to talk about them
people coming across the border and that
fentanyl that fentanyl your brother your
cousin Donny's doing that's a problem
now Daryl
oh I know Donnie personally I know
Donnie personally and that some [__]
does more than fentanyl I guarantee you
because he ain't sleeping all the time
yeah but anyways Chad
you know immigration once they got out
of her way we got to do what we're doing
illegal immigration dropped by 70 and
it's nothing but talking points with him
now you got the Santa's down here flying
around in a helicopter with his blue
jeans on Texas and Texas in Texas you
know where is did he wear his white
boots when he went to death no no I
think
I figured he thought those cheerleader
boots yeah well you know I figured if he
had worn his white boots Tony I would be
laying on this floor still laughing
hysterically I thought I figured
he'd like it because they look really
similar to like the Dallas Cowboy
Cheerleaders boots I mean they look very
similar so hey bigger that's not a joke
man I would I saw them boots I thought
cheerleader boots
I mean I'm gonna be honest when I saw
those boots uh the first thing that I
thought about I don't know if you guys
ever watched in Reno 9-1-1
but when there's the part where he's
like I just spend my money on some new
boot just new boot goofing
speaking nothing like a new pair of
boots
you need three-toed boots uh Marjorie
Taylor green tweeted out the crust she
tweeted out the uh the clip yesterday
the distraction clip uh that's gonna
distract their base from the you mean
the clip that they cut like three
seconds off well uh RNC research which
that's [__] gold research
they account RNC research put out this
clip and she she embedded the uh clip
here and it says the quotes of course
this is the quote I sold a lot of State
secrets and a lot of very important
things I think he's making fun of
someone else when he says this I believe
that's what he's doing I don't know if
they know that you know they suck at
comedy right they really suck at satire
they suck at parody so it's not
surprising that they don't get a joke
when they hear it
um she she goes on to say Joe Biden's
brain is going and he's literally
admitting to crimes out loud imp each
Biden it's unreal and so insulting to
America listen he can't be the I mean
just the other day she was saying he was
The Mastermind uh behind the Russia
destabilization and he's also the
Mastermind behind the uh the submarine
the Ocean Gate submarine said that they
he could cover up Hunter Biden which was
in the news I heard about it I don't
know you guys I mean we talked about it
on the show extensively it was actually
the lead into one of our shows about the
plea deals that Hunter Biden had
um but here's a clip and I can show the
clip but it just it they just clicked
the part where he says the joke they
don't they don't clip it to have contact
because they don't understand comedy
well they the best part is they miss the
laughing right like laughing and then
all kidding aside right right exactly
because it was a joke and he was making
fun of uh what's the last guy who had
was president who uh who's charged on 37
felony counts of the Espionage Act which
we heard a clip yesterday of him
committing crime actually on tape by
showing people not only showing them a
document but telling them can't exist
what's that guy's name I forget God damn
it's like they worship him or something
yeah uh uh toilet no uh Trump
okay so here's the community notes on
this because that's the thing that
happened is RNC research put this out
there Texas ball on the internet which
is all a bunch of [__] but um the
community notes was uh in high uh they
had a lot of work last night to follow
this around this video around and they
had to put Community notes on this video
because it says the video has been
edited so as to leave out important
context in order to misrepresent a joke
as an admission of guilt in the unedited
video linked below the president
concludes all kidding aside again all
kidding aside he's making fun of the
Cheeto dusk Q anoner is what he's making
fun of that the dude stole documents and
he probably sold them that's what he's
saying that's what he's saying he's not
saying he did he's making fun of the
last guy that made it look like he's
doing that Texas ball don't you think
that's what the joke was don't you think
yeah absolutely and I I have to tell you
man this is just I mean just
as somebody that does what I do for a
living I I absolutely live for this kind
of thing I absolutely live for this
Marjorie Trader green is going to put
solar panels on my roof she is I mean
this kind of stuff is just Priceless
because people but and the Beautiful
part is you tell people that she said
this and she did this and they're like
no no no and then you show them the
video and or the tweet and they're like
no [__] I mean it is the best thing that
is and in 2024
I mean think about all the hunter Biden
[__] they threw out there that we've
just torn apart all the Joe Biden [__]
we've torn apart and in 2024 they
actually think this is going to work for
them and they're running with it hard I
love it man because it's like watching a
guy run into it is literally the clip
from The Simpsons
the rate clip from The Simpsons it is
literally that in real yeah it is in
real life I mean
and then they go down to Ace Hardware
and buy more rakes
I say let's order them dump trucks of
shovels and rakes I'm fine with it I'm
absolutely fine with it let's do that
and the Beautiful part about it is we're
not even having to we're not even doing
it we're not the one throwing the rates
out for them they're doing it themselves
well here's another prime example of it
here's uh Senator Rick Scott now I don't
know if you know this Gabe Sanchez you
kind of know this guy a little bit but I
have a bit of history with his daughter
and by that I mean I work with her and
I've met Rick Scott and his
demon wife once and
let me tell you he is the most
uninteresting
man well you're gonna see that in this
you're gonna see that in this clip not
only is he a senator now he's a he's a a
former Medicare fraudster and health
care fraudster I made all kinds of money
but he closed down pulling locations
well that's because you can cream of the
crop here that's because he's he was the
governor did you know hey text Paul did
you know that a Governor's job of a
state is to get people to come and spend
tourist dollars to their state did you
know that that's one of their jobs that
sounds pretty woke guys wow especially a
state like Florida when like their
entire industry is uh I don't know
tourism I mean like that's the that's
the one thing they got right yeah I mean
who else would go to that [__] state
for anything right now it's a [__]
hell hole
I will bet you even that Maga freak
restaurant guy that Fox News keeps
pulling out of their butt every time
there's something woke going on you know
he was up on in the Bud Light commercial
took one look at this video from Rick
Scott and said
Whoa man what are you saying man stop
stop I mean this is this is just
literally have y'all have y'all ever
seen that video that went around the
internet of the guy he's got the little
nine millimeters about this big and he
takes his testicles out and he puts one
of the testicles on the table and then
shoots it what that's a real video
shoots his own that's a real video man
that is a real video guy shoots his own
testicle I mean it was viral it went
everything
I do okay hold on I do know about a
video that came out in
2007 it was called uh and I don't want
people to look this up because it is
graphic maybe this is what you're
talking about it's called Pain Olympics
yeah and this one this dude cut it off
he cut his dick off no I've seen that
one this guy literally wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait he cut his dick
off or cut his balls off no he got his
dick off whoa
he was gross anyway
one
speaking of cutting a dick off
um Rick Scott here the Crypt Keeper he
decides it's a good idea to tell people
not to come to his State because wait I
got another question though yeah go
ahead if Rick Scott and Ron DeSantis are
going after these communist socialist
woke [__] that right you know
uh [__] spread their pride flags all
over Disney World okay uh what happens
if these elected officials alienate
everyone from ever coming to Florida or
Disney World like what happens at the
Super Bowl because people say I'm going
to Disney like what where do they go now
where are they gonna go New York City
California we got Disneyland I guess
they can come here Disneyland now
here's a here's the crazy part to me
about this clip is again Rick Scott used
to be the governor like it was part of
his daily job to make sure that people
would still come to a state and here in
this clip now I I have to say too again
this guy is not only a senator a sitting
United States center for the State of
Florida he's a former Governor but he's
also a a former Medicare fraudster this
guy has lived off socialism he made his
fortune off socialism by stealing
[__] government money by defrauding A
system that is a socialist system okay
so like this guy is oh man it's just
hilarious now the other thing too that a
lot of people don't understand about
Florida is that the the population
makeup the demographic there it's kind
of I don't want to say this nicely old
it's old there's a lot of people on
Medicare and Social Security in that
state which is um what the hell is that
called what kind of system is that when
you uh take uh government money you pull
it together and then you disperse it uh
amongst the population when the
government like socialism oh yeah that's
right that's right it's called socialism
and it's funny okay I couldn't be so not
only not only is this guy a [__] a a
[__] bank account that is represented
by socialism the state itself and he
knows this he's a [__] Governor he's
sitting United States interview he
doesn't know this he needs his head
examined but it the thing is is that his
estate a large pop piece of the
population of his state is made up of
their entire living is made up of
socialism but let's hear what he wants
to tell people not to come to Florida
let's listen sooner Rick Scott here let
me give you a travel warning if you're a
socialist
communist somebody that believes in big
government I would think twice think
twice if you're thinking about taking a
vacation or moving to Florida now is
this a threat I mean honestly it kind of
sounds like a threat it also sounds like
he's just saying hey if you uh ever want
to live in a state that ever needs
government Aid like I don't know let's
say that you live in a state or want to
visit a state that has an annual [__]
hurricane that comes through and you
need some sort of government assistance
or like FEMA you know God forbid you
ever want to want to fix or maintain
your state but let's say that there was
a state like that I don't know let's say
it's Florida I don't know hypothetically
let's say it's Florida that there's
something that happens every single year
annually and sometimes more than once a
year
uh causes Devastation and destruction
Rick Scott basically says that you yeah
[__] socialism any of that right yeah
like we're a state that's able to be
independent because we don't like
socialism
is that what I'm hearing right here
that's what I hear Texas Paul you've
probably been threatened before in your
life I'm sure you live in Texas right
um
is that a thing I don't know if it's the
thing in Texas a week and a half ago
ah Texas Paul did you you see this I
mean I'm gonna play the rest of the clip
but so far did you think this is a
threat I mean it kind of sounds like it
right yeah well he he says it played out
I'm warning you all right I'm warning
you I mean this is the biggest load of
[__] I've ever seen man stop me stop
me from coming
this is a great I would say you know a
lot of States like there's the Pure
Michigan like come to Michigan and
experience the great lakes and all this
stuff right this is the opposite of a
tourist ad this is like don't you
[__] dick every single day we do this
every single day we do this and we
stumble upon a great piece of art that
is a potential and I think there is a
great great vacation in Florida ad that
could be created here I'm just I'm
saying where you can don't worry the the
tape that when we get to the tape one I
can't reveal what it is on the air but
there's a tape one that I already wrote
the script for it's oh great you talking
about the Trump tapes which tapes the
Nixon tapes no no no no no no no no the
Trump tapes okay well let's listen to
the rest of Rick Scott's uh taped uh uh
threat here let's let's listen we're the
free state of Florida we actually don't
believe in socialism we actually know
people and we some people actually lived
under it we know people lived in our
socialism it's not good it's not good
for anybody so if you're thinking about
it if you think about coming to Florida
and your social communist think twice we
like Freedom Liberty capitalism things
like that do we like
capitalism
along those lines Tony to go along with
what Gabe just said yeah
when hurricane Ian blew through
they've got this stupid volunteer hybrid
Disaster Response system in Florida
right I mean it really is it's literally
that sounds kind of coming to me yeah
case Casey DeSantis was put in charge of
part of it for a while I mean it was
just it's nonsense idiocy and when Ian
blew through
Florida it failed so badly that when you
opened their web page it said call FEMA
wait wait wait it's a cola FEMA so tell
me you don't love you some socialism
when you know hurricane Ian just tore us
through your state and you're like call
FEMA well let me tell you something
folks FEMA is socialism it is it is
absolutely one of the most
perfect examples of socialism and it
works you know I'm not a scared I'm not
scared of it I love big government I
love that I love being able to take and
throw me a steak on the grill when I cut
that damn thing open it moves at me
and I'm not scared that that thing
yeah
I do I go I
did you know same joke I'll tell the
waitresses all the time when I go to go
to a steakhouse or like how would you
like that cooked I tell them the same
thing knock the horns off of it and
bring it back you know I mean it's
it's you know that's the point from The
Cowboy Way you know that that is it yeah
so there's a line in The Cowboy Way with
Woody Harrelson and Kiefer Sutherland
Sutherland and they're in a fancy uh New
York establishment I'm sure they had
cold New York yeah I know cold cold
ovens there and that in that
establishment but he asked Howie you'd
like it and then prepared and he's like
not good times older than I am Tony
old ass he says knock its horns off wipe
its nasty old ass and chunk it right
down on the plate that's what he says in
the movie that line is older than I am
my daddy used to say that and man I'm
telling her Daddy what about your
daddy's Daddy
no my daddy's Daddy had a real thick
German accent from up North so yeah I
see
but I'm telling you man
you don't fear it why don't you fear it
why don't you fear eating a raw ass
steak
because the government inspections well
because of government inspections
government I don't I gotta I gotta tell
you though uh I recently saw a video
maybe like a month ago where people were
throwing Quarters on stakes and they
were saying that there was some magnetic
properties going on well that's because
it was from the brown people place okay
that's why they were brown people Stakes
I'm telling you that's what it was
that's what they said people are so
[__] stupid they aren't actually you
know what I just got news from our
friend Boston Smalls he's got a video
here this is uh breaking news
um he's got a talking about video clips
um this apparently is a clip of Elon and
Zuckerberg I'm gonna show it to you
right here here it is here's the here is
the um
okay
now that this can't be right this can't
be right this that can't be right that
can't be right what I heard was is Elon
is like yeah I'll kick your ass but my
mom won't let me do it so uh we we can't
fight because my mommy won't let me did
you hear that did you hear that's the
news his mom won't let him fight oh my
God oh my God talk about a [__] ass
[__] man just really really waiting for
for your mom to step in that's kind of
like when everyone was like Hey Elon
doesn't know how to run a company and
he's [__] hemorrhaging money at
Twitter and then his mom came in and was
like hey everyone should stop picking on
my son this is how companies are
actually run and it's like you you don't
know either you also benefited from
these Emerald mines like the fact that
you have to have your mom on Twitter
come to your defense because people are
bullying you on the platform that you
own
my God it's crazy
yeah go ahead go ahead textbook when I
was a kid
I ran away from a fight once I didn't I
[__] [__] chicken [__] it out and ran
I felt like [__] for so long I can still
it's still when I think about it I have
a visceral reaction to it I would rather
take a beating from Mike frickin Tyson
then I would run away from a freaking
fight man I am telling you have you have
you watched Mike Tyson even work out
with a set of boxing gloves on he's like
in his 60s he would murder you yeah I
mean I know you're I know you're a tough
guy but Mike Tyson would absolutely
[__] murder you oh he would kick my
ass what up one side of the block and
back down the other I have no doubt but
I would run Ash is one level kicking ass
is one level Mike Tyson would actually
destroy you
come out on the middle of a social media
platform
and get me out of a fight I would I
would rather I would rather have Mark
Zuckerberg kick my ass than I would
you know I'm old now man I used to throw
hands like crazy I still will but it's
it's it's not what I used to be zuck's
got a good chance man that dude is like
he's into that Krav Maga [__] and all
that other stuff yeah yeah well you know
you know that's funny you say that
because um I I think
the embarrassment of getting your ass
kicked by Zuckerberg
um is the same level of getting pounded
to your death by Mike Tyson that really
is some Ultra I got a quick story for
you so so Mike Tyson uh if anyone knows
this uh Mike Tyson has definitely turned
himself around in the sense of he isn't
so [__] aggressive uh and and violent
right now he still will be violent if he
needs to be in the ring you know or or
on a plane that we saw
but but
uh he also is big into you know
marijuana and also shrooms so he he came
into Chicago and my brother's a
photographer and a videographer and he
worked with a buddy's
um
a buddy's team to shoot Mike Tyson
because he's got the he's got the the
Tyson bites right the little there's
Vander Holyfield's here is it is it mush
is it mushroom those aren't those are
those aren't those are those are edibles
but he also takes mushrooms and my
brother was telling me they were out and
they were shooting around Chicago
and uh
and they were on they were on they were
somewhere on set and like filming
interactions with people and all of a
sudden my brother's recording uh Mike
Tyson and then he calls out to one of
his like assistants he's like hey where
are the shrooms and then this assistant
comes [__] running in with a little
baggie of shrooms and he's like here
here because he's he's just like micro
dosing and taking stuff as it is but it
was my brother was like it was so crazy
to see this this person that we grew up
watching this like [__] beast of all
like in and out of the ring right and
then seeing him in person he's like dude
he's like the most
nice gentle person now
but it's such like a a stark contrast to
what we've seen previously
to now he's just like taking shrooms out
in the open and just like super chill so
the fact that it's Gotta Be the shrooms
though right yeah totally but it's also
like in that moment in that moment on
the plane uh they even offered that dude
shrooms they're like dude can you just
[__] chill do you want some shrooms
or whatever like just don't don't piss
Mike off all right stop and the fact
that he's like he's gonna beat this [__]
out of you more chill now after doing
those things like the fact you have to
do that and you piss him off that says
something
there's a whole subsection of dumb asses
that do think like you know like Conor
McGregor guy's an [__] he is he's
just an [__] he's an arrogant jackass
he really is an [__] but I am never
going to run up to Conor McGregor and
call him an [__] I'm just not going
to do it because Conor McGregor will
kick my ever loving ass he will I mean
it's just that simple I mean yeah I will
throw hands I will defend my wife's
honor I will take an ass whipping but I
don't volunteer for ass weapons I don't
and but there is like that guy on the
plane with Mike Tyson there's just this
whole subset of dumbasses that find
somebody that professionally kicks ass
he doesn't just kick dumb asses asses
off the street he kicks people's asses
that do this professionally train for it
prepare for it get into a ring knowing
what the hell they're doing he beats the
[__] out of those people but your dumb
ass is gonna run up and pick it Mike
Tyson over his seat for an hour and a
half until Mike Tyson stands up and
beats your ever loving ass into
unconsciousness it really was I mean
there is an invite though it really
wasn't I mean he threw a couple hands
and it was over I mean this guy didn't
stand a [__] chance just like it was
sure just like Roseanne Barr sorry I I
don't mean to Pivot but I got I gotta
pivot the Roseanne Barr Roseanne Barr
doesn't stand a chance against the
internet with this [__] clip here on
Theo Von's podcast
um I you know this you know what
surprises me most about this clip not
that Roseanne Barr is a Nutty [__]
lunatic and she's just off her rocker
but that Theo Von is nodding his head
going along with everything she says
that that surprises the [__] yeah I
don't think I don't think he knew what
to say when she was saying this I'd like
to hear Theos uh and honestly he come on
the show Theo man I I don't know what
you're thinking because when I'm
listening to her say this I'm like this
is nuttier than squirrel turds so I
think that's kind of what was going
through his head he didn't know what to
say really to what Roseanne's about to
say but listen to what she says about
the Holocaust it's [__] wild [__] see
that's the truth and don't you dare say
anything against her you'll be off
YouTube Facebook Twitter and all the
other ones because we have you know
there's such a thing as the truth and
facts and we have to stick to it and um
you know okay it's scary
and that is the truth and nobody died in
the Holocaust either well that's the
whoa whoa whoa that took a while that
took a wild jump it took a wild jump
because I think what she's talking about
is vaccines right I don't know the lead
into this I don't know what she's
talking about what happened after he was
like yep like you cut it off right there
and I'm like Theo seems really nervous
Theo seems really nervous like in the
beginning of this clip and and all of a
sudden he she takes this left turn to
the Holocaust Texas Paul now what she
says next is even [__] worse like you
would think oh that's the worst she
could say about this but it gets worse
Texas Ball but what do you think's going
through Theo's head because that's
really what I want to know like because
he's sitting there like I don't know
where this is go because he's trying not
to say anything it seems like to me
because he's like this is getting this
is getting out of hand right in shape
have you ever been in that situation man
where somebody just goes
and then all of a sudden you got this
I do it every Tuesday here with YouTube
every [__] Tuesday we go we go from
[__] banana bread to chopping off um
people's dicks on videos so yeah I mean
we do it like I said Tuesday's got terms
every Tuesday we do this no but but I'm
serious Theo Theo here now now watch his
body language because a lot of people
get Theo [__] here but I I see his body
language and what I see is what you're
saying Texas ball he doesn't know what
the [__] to say he didn't know what the
[__] to do he can't get any words to
come out of his mouth uh it's really
weird but again I want to know his
thought process behind this interview
but listen to what this
this [__] lunatic says it gets worse
one the truth yeah it should happen six
million Jews should die right now
because they cause all the problems in
the world but
what what what what what
so not only not only did she say this is
[__] nuts okay now it's it's kind of
laughable and the reason why it's
laughable is because it's it's expected
from these manga idiots like you expect
this the other thing that you don't know
and she's gonna say it she's [__]
Jewish
what the [__] are you talking about that
means it's okay right well right it's
okay for her to say that but but listen
not only did she say the Holocaust
didn't happen but she's saying it should
happen like this is the [__] that Nick
Fuentes says the [__] guy who took
Kanye West down to the Nazi that took
Kanye West to go eat dinner with Donald
Trump and then one on Alex Jones's
podcast and several others and said I
love Hitler I [__] love Hitler Hitler
was a good guy Hitler knew what he was
doing but that's that's the [__] I mean
when people when people say like oh but
she's Jewish it's like that doesn't mean
there aren't [__] white supremacists
who are black or Latino or Asian or
whatever there are people within those
communities who who help bolster and
amplify those ideologies those bigoted
racist terrible ideologies and just
because she's Jewish doesn't mean that
oh well she's doing she can make those
jokes that's not a [__] joke
that's a statement that she believes is
a fact that should happen six million
Jews should be killed because they
they're the problem like whoa whoa and
that's the stupid thing Texas Paul
that's the stupid thing it's this thing
that Joe Rogan does right where they're
like no I'm a because Theo is a comedian
too so is Roseanne Archie used to be
she's not [__] funny anymore but Theo
is a comedian Roseanne used to be uh Joe
Rogan is they do this stuff where
they're like well it's just comedy it's
just jokes does it sound like does it
sound like that was a joke to you Texas
Paul oh that was dead serious comment
and I tell you this is where I slightly
disagree with you Tony yeah go ahead I
don't defend I don't defend him because
there are situations that's what I was
leading up to when I said that there are
situations where guests say things and
they've got some note or some popularity
so you can't you know you just don't
want to you kind of want to nudge it
back in the right direction but the
correct response to what she said was to
say
excuse me
and give them a chance to repeat what
they say and if she repeats what the
[__] she just said the correct response
is get the [__] off of my show
right I mean that that is the right
response to that state that because that
wasn't a joke Tony
well I mean she may think that it's not
her defense of it is going to be that
it's a joke that may be her defense but
I think she I think well I think we've
heard this before from from when she
came after
um is this when she got canceled she
actually canceled yeah this isn't it it
was islamophobic right uh you know it
was a joke
but she had a similar response right but
there's an interview and she's backstage
when she was when on the reboot of
Roseanne and she was like it was a
[__] joke it was a joke it's right
freaking out right I mean well look it
up while you're looking that up let's
finish the clip here because it it I
don't know how it could get worse
uh but it does never happens but it
never happened yeah mandated
well you're because you're part Jewish
right party family's Jewish I'm all
Jewish you're all Jewish 100 and a lot
of Hollywood is Jewish yeah it's like a
it's a
a lot of Hollywood is a Jewish business
really well they started Hollywood yeah
right but so was it weird it's like rap
black people started rap yeah so I
wouldn't go over there and try to get
and wrap them and go all these black
people you know go on Saturday Night
Live Like Dave Chappelle uh I'm just
saying a lot of black people are in
control of rap right hello
well you went there you try to get in
Show Business of course it's Jewish but
you know and people should be glad that
it's Jewish too because if Jews were not
controlling Hollywood all you'd have was
[__] fishing shows yeah yeah I
honestly honestly I have to agree with
her there it would be [__] if [__]
creative smart people weren't in control
of Hollywood they just happened to be
Jewish I mean it would be shitty if not
if right-wingers were actually in
control of Hollywood it would be
absolute garbage I don't know if you've
if you've watched Kevin sarbo or
whatever the [__] his name is his
Twitter feed but it's it's not good and
and Roseanne you getting to the right
wing made you so unfunny you're just not
funny at all you're nuttier than a
squirrel turd and Nana nutso here I want
to show you another video
um because our friend uh not hoodum
posted this video of her which is wild
this is um this is real this is really
her this is not uh AI I don't know that
anyone would do AI of Roseanne but uh
here's here's a selfie video
you know what I think you know just
that's amongst yourselves okay I don't
agree sure you have to burn it the steak
for just before not agreeing with me let
me just throw out one idea okay
and I hope
that the hungry dogs in the street have
enough meat as not to come after me for
thinking and speaking
I'm tired of it but
I have this to say as follows and it's
okay I say because nobody loves the
[__] thing I say which is great
I'm tired of being monitored you know
corrected and [__] [__] it
I'm gonna say what I'm gonna say
Trump
hear me when I say this
Trump is in my opinion mm-hmm
the first woman president of the United
States
um I I wish I had a great response to
this but folks I I would imagine that
Theo Bond knew this clip existed of her
and was like yeah yeah let's have her on
the show let's get her in front of a
microphone let's get her to say whatever
the [__] she wants to say that way these
clips go viral [__] because bring her
on that clip has you know it's like what
three years old now and that's crazy
[__] it is still actually you know what
I oh wow I think we literally just
passed the three year anniversary I
think it was like June 20 something
2020. like June 25th
that's [__] nut anyway but there's a
the video I was talking about is
Roseanne Barr and she freaks out because
it's her response to the Valerie Jarrett
tweet which got her canceled so I you
know in this one vulture article says
it's been nearly two months since ABC
decided to cancel Roseanne following
Barr's racist tweet about former Barack
Obama aide Valerie Jarrett and since
then she had a very tearful interview
but in the interview she's like it was a
joke it was a joke like what and she
dude she looks [__] disheveled she's
smoking it's not a great look especially
someone who has made millions of dollars
she's [__] rich but here she is Rich
I've seen videos of Roseanne Barr in her
home with her son and I don't know if
somebody stole her money or she spent
all her money but the situation in which
she lives
she is you know how rich she is she is I
own a Kona coffee Plantation in Hawaii
Rich yeah I mean speakers in Hawaii and
there ain't acres to own in Hawaii and
and that's what's so bad about this guys
is that her life could be beautiful I
mean it literally she can wake up every
morning in Kona Hawaii looking out at
the Pacific Ocean just having this
beautiful life and this is where her
demented sick freaking head is
all the time apparently because the
woman cannot get in front of a
microphone without without you know just
you know shooting herself I mean it's
just
what the hell man q a is a hell of a
drug Q Anon is a hell of a drug man it's
a hell of a drug that's that's all I
gotta say
um I I know the audience is like the
[__] said he's gonna play the
clip of trump when is he gonna play the
clip of trump I'm gonna play it I
promise eventually we're we're gonna get
to it I I swear but I gotta show you um
speaking of celebrities now this is a
different this is a different level of
celebrity and he's [__] Rich too but
this morning Arnold Schwarzenegger
[__] just burns
Jeffrey Clark to the ground now do you
remember Jeffrey Clark and uh in the
Donald Trump Saga Texas do you remember
Jeffrey Clark okay Jeffrey Clark is give
us a synopsis if you remember who he is
Jeffrey Clark would
um worked in
um
but he was part of the administration he
he was a just a pathetic little nobody
horrible person he's the guy that
answered the front door with like no
pants on when they when the reporters
came yeah this is Jeffrey Clark
this is Jeffrey they were going to try
to make him district attorney
and the guy is just
I mean he's nobody he's a [__] the
entire doj in whole when it came out
we're gonna make Jeffrey Clark attorney
general
every professional prosecutor in the doj
stood up at the same time and said we
will resign
if you make this guy attorney general
he's a trump sycophant he is nobody he
was a he was an assistant assistant to
the assistant district attorney and his
only claim to fame was that he would
he's a trump sicker fan he will say and
do anything he's part of the you know
I'm pushing it now guys yeah there's a
deep state but it's a republican deep
state right I mean because you have a
government filled with Jeffrey Clarks
well here's the here's the back and
forth here now this back and forth with
Arnold and the reason why I bring this
up is because this is actually big news
um big news as Dashner Broski would say
big news
um this is actually some news that is
coming out of the Supreme Court but
Arnold back on October 26th uh 2022 so
this is last year he says this is my
Amicus brief in uh more verse Harper the
test of so-called independent state
legislator Theory at the Supreme Court
you have to be polite at scotus but here
are my unfiltered thoughts frankly this
theory is nuts so in other words he
gives it in a thread
of what he thinks of more verse Harper
now
um game index ball for the audience that
doesn't know more verse Harper is one of
the Republicans plans to overturn the
2024 election it's one of their plans
the other one of their plans was 2022 we
headed that plan off by voting engaging
our democracy making sure that
Pennsylvania uh Arizona Michigan and
Wisconsin got a Democratic governor
attorney general and Secretary of State
because their their mission was to just
overturn the election in 2024 with those
States because that's the states that
Donald Trump would have needed more than
likely uh to win for them to cheat and
to just overturn the election with we
know what they couldn't do in 2020
winning loss that's why they're so mad
that's why they're so pissed off that's
why they stormed the capital they tried
to do a coup in an Insurrection and
Jeffrey Clark is part of that to an
Insurrection
um but there's a little bit of back and
forth because Jeffrey Clark decided it
was a good idea it was a good idea to
respond to Arnold here now again this is
back last year he says you know a faux
Republican when Arnold and I I believe
that's what he was trying to do
is this a d mouth bald to file an amicus
brief at the Supreme Court one authored
by significant Democrat Supreme Court
practitioner David Frederick blah blah
blah blah blah right so Jeffrey Clark's
like [__] you Arnie right basic in basic
terms [__] you you're stupid you don't
know what you're talking about right yes
that's the guy who
had to stand outside in his uh in a
dress shirt and boxers
because he tried to commit a coup right
in the 2020 election well he was on a
response now this is the back and forth
okay and I'm gonna get to the news here
um but this is Arnold's in real time his
response to Jeffrey's little Arnold
you're stupid
um he says
thanks for the kind message I love this
photo of you but if you want some tips
on squatting to build up those legs I'm
here for you
okay so Arnold obviously is leaning into
the comedy here right right but this
morning this morning Arnold owns the
internet and the reason why is because
this morning the Amicus brief that that
was written
um actually went Arnold's way uh he says
hi Jeff I know the Supreme Court went
with my more vs Harper and not yours but
I'm still here for for leg training tips
you can get some free workouts and
positivity here it might help you and
then he he plugs Arnold's pumpclub.com
um to really dig his knife I was really
hoping I was really hoping that go back
to the Tweet yeah that it would say like
hi Jeff I know the Supreme Court well my
way more was Harper and not yours but
I'm still here for late 20th tips you
can get some free workouts and
positivity here and it might help you go
to
arnoldspumpclub.com and use promo code
Jeff
it would have been so much better if he
would have had a promo code now Texas
Paul tell us why this I know the back
and forth is funny where Arnold is
dunking on Jeffrey Clark here it's
hilarious right but tell me why this
Supreme Court decision is so important
because it really is truly important
because the Republicans are trying to
make it to where they can overturn an
election exactly you can distill it down
to just that one point right there this
case
was the North Carolina
Republican legislature trying to say
they had the ability
solely to run elections and the federal
government could screw off there's
nothing they can do about it literally
for it
the federal government to get involved
in an election would have to become
would have to come from Congress itself
it would have to take an act of Congress
itself to be voted on go through the
legislative process and the whole point
of that folks is to try to slow things
down we had a Supreme Court decision
that uh that allowed they created a
situation where the onus is on the uh us
to to
let me back up you used to have
oversight from the federal government uh
in which that if you wanted to make a
change to a map or a change to uh voting
polling locations or whatnot in certain
States they had to come to the federal
government and say hey we're doing this
in advance that was Stripped Away by the
Supreme Court so now the Republicans
wait until the very last day to make
changes then they throw these bogus Maps
out
knowing that you're really short on time
between that day and the election
here come the court challenges from us
to fight them and the Supreme Court has
ruled that well no it's too close to an
election so we've got a lot of my stand
and you are you later
so they end up with both Madden place
then we find out after the there have
been rulings that have overruled these
Maps post-election but then nobody wants
to redo the election nobody wants to you
know destabilize our government by
pulling people out of it so anyways
long story short too late
um this decision more re versus Harper
would have codified it so that
local folks
Greg Abbott here in Texas could just run
the election any damn way he chooses and
it would literally take an act of
Congress
to overturn anything he does right and
the Supreme Court rightfully said
uh no right equal protections Clause
under the the Constitution says
everybody gets is entitled to a fair
election in every state you can't just
willingly radically do this stuff these
these states can't run the elections as
they wish they run the elections based
on the laws that exist
um speaking and I know I'm moving along
here but I gotta I gotta get to the clip
okay everyone wants to hear the clip so
I'm going to show you this clip this is
ah this is this is um what appears to be
someone in support of Hunter Biden being
impeached now I actually after watching
this I was like you know what this is
this is um this actually there's not
some bad arguments in here at the end
this is this I I could get behind some
of this let's let's listen look here I
want to tell y'all something I've been
thinking about this whole
Hunter Biden thing yeah first of all I
don't think he needs to be president
anymore let's get that out of the way
first off
but this whole thing with him as a
constitution
Republican as a fiscal
fiscal physical as a physical
conservative Constitution Republican
bald eagle machine gun alpha male
Republican
I was really against
um Hunter Biden because I saw some of
his videos and he's got a his peckers
the size of a PBR tall boy and I was
like that's too big and then he's like
having tons of sex like the guy gets
laid all the time I'm like nobody needs
to have a pecker that big or get laid
that much and so I was mad
I was mad mostly about that but then
also because people were telling me I
should be mad and I wasn't 100 sure why
but I knew that I should and I think
Donald Trump maybe told me I should so I
was mad and I'm still mad I guess but
then I just heard that the thing they
that they got him as far as breaking a
law he had a gun he wasn't supposed to
have and he was trying to not pay taxes
and now I'm like well
that's kind of my thing is
you know you know I'm like
my hand that big old pecker
I mean I think this guy might be an
alpha
hey okay okay obviously that is 100 real
yeah but you know what don't need a fact
check it guys you know what's hilarious
so good Texas Paul you know a lot of
these obviously a satire and parody but
you know a lot of [__] that
talk like this can't you see their logic
leading them in that direction and they
not even they run straight smack into it
not even know it I you know man I was
sitting here actually in physical pain
when you first pulled that up because I
was like oh God this is going to be a
southern guy I know it I know it I
thought it was real for a second I'm
like this is going to be a southern guy
and then the accent rolled out oh [__]
here we go here we go and then okay that
was freaking golden I mean that was
beautiful man you know because put it
any better way could you could you no I
mean when you're dealing with the dude
with a PBR tall boy as a as a pecker he
does have a huge hog apparently I've
never I've never searched this laptop to
to um to jerk off to the pictures of
Hunter Biden but apparently he's don't
have to search it every damn Republican
on the planet's been trying to get me to
look at it I mean they you know people
people like uh Matt Gates they have
thumb drives all of the contents right
of the laptop on the thumb drive he
walks around with it on his keychain
whatever people he plugs it into
whatever computer he can put it into
right right well you think that's a
pretty good part no pun intended that's
pretty good that's a pretty good party
trick for Matt Gantz though he's like
yeah he's like hey come over here let me
show you a big old dick yeah and they're
like yeah okay uh and they think he's
gonna when he pulls out his laptop well
he goes I mean she goes to a party he's
always like how old are you guys oh oh
you're under 18 great cool yeah we're
good but also when Matt Gates goes to
Junior High School proms
um or dances
he makes sure to go to the DJ and
campaigning he's camping he's
campaigning campaign yeah yeah right
right that's that's what it's called
can't wait yeah campaigning that's right
well when he goes to these like Junior
High School you know junior high school
dances or or High School proms
uh he shows up and he goes to the DJ and
he says hey man I've got a playlist that
I want you to to show and they're like
no I'm I'm good I don't need to like
I've got Spotify and I got music and I
got a whole mixing board and everything
he's like no no believe me I got stuff
that these kids are gonna like and then
he sticks it in the [__] thumb drive
into the laptop and you know the
computer also crashes but the guy who's
the DJ is like holy [__] what the [__]
you just put on here
goes up on the display and that's Matt
Gates's party trick he will show up
uninvited to a dance that is a bunch of
kids to show Hunter Biden's dick and say
look I've been studying this dick for
years
[Laughter]
do they email you the because some
people are saying they're they're
commenting that all the Republicans are
trying to show you Hunter Biden's dick
do they oh man what do you do they email
them or do they fax it to you how do
they what are they how did you miss this
on social media man every post I put up
for a good section there as soon as the
pictures came out they were linking to
them all the damn time and put them up
on Twitter they were getting account
bands Tony
for putting Hunter Biden's joke out on
there I finally had I did own the lips
but you know I did this video actually
does bring up a very interesting point
let's say he doesn't want to pay his
taxes he's got a a an illegal gun that
he carries around apparently
um he you know he likes to screw around
on his wife and you know likes to screw
around with you know women does blow
does you know all that's I'm starting to
think that Hunter Biden might be more of
a republican than Robert Kennedy is a
Democrat
that's not that's not a bad Theory I
don't know that that could be it that
could be it
oh my God but the logic there honestly
the step through the logic and the pan
is in this set
oh my god dude I think we can actually
convince him of this [__] oh yeah
convince them of this [__] like why are
you against because I've been saying
since Hunter Biden took the plea deal
I'm like the 2A Bros should be [__]
pissed of the charred the gun charge was
the ATF coming after what the [__] they
should be they should they should that's
what they should be mad about the most
in the honor Biden case is that that
charge not only did he plead to it but
that [__] thing exists in their
uninfringible right it's really funny
speaking of insanity
um grandpa Poopypants uh the Cheeto desk
you and honor threatens Jack Smith now
this was
oh this was his response to the tape
um
oh my God it's an audio recording it
when we listen to it it feels like to me
that either I I think he knew it was
being recorded like he knew it felt like
to me that there was a tape recorder
near him it wasn't like in someone's
pocket or something it was near him when
you hear this it's clear it's Daya what
he's saying like he was leaning into the
mic to say it but here's here's his post
on fraud social in response to CNN
dropping this audio tape after he leaked
it to him because that's that's what
[__] happened here it happened yeah
right and I'm going to show you in this
statement that it happened he said the
Duran special prosecutor Jack Smith
working in conjunction with the doj and
FBI illegally leaked the spun a tape
okay and transcript to me which is
actually an exoneration okay so you
think it's an exoneration one and you're
saying that in conjunction with doj and
FBI Jack Smith leaked this you think
it's an exoneration but you're mad that
it leaked to CNN
tell me that you leaked this tape
without telling me or just say just say
it out loud with your projection your
confession Texas Paul am I [__] wrong
here this guy leaked this thing no this
is this is actually he thinks this is a
winning legal strategy he the tape is
damning as hell he knows that Jack Smith
has it so he leaks it
knowing that what 80 80 what do you
speculate 80 90 of his people aren't
going to watch or listen to the tape
they aren't they're going to disregard
it out of hand because he's told them oh
it's bull it's it's nothing it's spun
it's it's this isn't real right it's
really his voice right killing himself
legally if Jack Smith could could walk
into court on this document's case put a
recorder down hit the button play the
tape I rest and sit down let me I mean
go back to the legal Theory thing
because you're you alluded to the fact
that Donald Trump thinks that this is a
good legal strategy by leaking this tape
and then saying this stuff why do you
think that because I'm thinking the same
thing you're thinking I think well why
do you think that's the legals his
Trump's legal strategy here I'm sure he
got it from like Tom Benton or something
uh it's not a good legal strategy but
why do you think he thinks it is
because it's so incredibly damning that
and a six-year-old can understand what
is said on this tape that he has to tell
his people in advance this is spun this
is fake this is government propaganda
this isn't really what you think it is
so they will dismiss it out of hand it
legally he is trying going for jury
nullification here is what he's doing
well actually so my theory is different
here's what I think he's trying to do I
think he's trying to get Canon to
believe this is my this is what I think
I'm serious I think the guy who wears
his little sister shirt was on the phone
with this [__] knew this tape
was gonna Buck knew they knew that if we
leaked this tape here's what could
happen we can get Cannon to believe that
Jack Smith leaked this tape and that
would take it out of evidence that would
take it out of Discovery she would throw
it out and say well you leaked it you
can use it now that's what they [__]
believe they believe this Theory and you
know what
that's also why I now believe that Jack
Smith put the transcript in the
indictment because I think that Donald
Trump had a copy of this [__] tape
the entire [__] time Jack Smith knew
he had a copy of this [__] he
knew he knew Donald Trump could leak
this at any moment and that's why they
put the transcript in the indictment so
that way no one can say well this can't
you can't this isn't admissible the
transcripts and the [__] indictment
the transcript's already public well
yeah Tony you know he knew it because he
recorded it that that is a recording
that was made
under his orders by his assistant right
this was not something that they they
tapped him or put a microphone in
Mar-A-Lago they literally recorded
themselves doing this and then her
Communications were seized by the doj or
subpoenaed by the doj so they knew this
recording went over to the doj they know
the doj has it as you said they put it
in the indictment and and they're just
trying to spin it they it was it's it's
idiocy I mean it's pure idiocy I mean
because I mean I hope you've got the
recording I really do because I got it
I'm actually going to play I'm actually
gonna he's been teasing I've been
teasing the whole time
the whole [__] show an hour
yeah I got you yeah but I do want to can
you oh you don't have to tweet up
anymore but
what again I think the thing that bugs
me the most yeah is the improper use of
quotes Okay so he says wait wait this
guy's committing [__] federal crimes
this guy's stealing documents he's
showing government Seekers to people who
shouldn't see it and the thing that
bothers you and this is typical Gabe
Sanchez style folks this is where the
rubber meets the road
[Music]
Dave Smith breaks out his red marking
pin and he's like we're gonna
the first thing my eyes want you to
write to the quote right to the quotes
and I was like these these quotes are
not used you are you are oh God quotes
should be used in a way to emphasize the
point you're trying to make and when you
misuse them and you put them on the
wrong [__] word it really grinds my
gears Tony it seems it seems that the
quotes piss off the
treasonage okay what really gets me
going Tony what really wakes me up in
the morning and gets me [__] agitated
is when people use the wrong quote usage
well you know this is where you come the
Tony Michaels podcast to get your
cathartic outrage with laughter when
we're laughing at [__] someone's
giving someone National Security uh
Secrets because in this I'm gonna play
it I promise I got it right here I I do
have it I do have that I'm glad Loki is
with me yeah well that's good so here's
the thing yeah you know that you know
you know somewhere in that audience
there is there is a teacher there is an
English teacher who is sitting there and
and not only is she I mean with Gabe
Sanchez she is actually punching up her
he is actually punching up the correct
terminology which none of us know
and this is the exact kind of quote it
is and this was not a representation of
it and this is why Gabe is absolutely
correct and why you pay attention in
school boys and girls that is why you
should not abolish the Department of
Education right that is why you should
not pay someone allegedly for taking the
GED for you after you allegedly didn't
pass it three times
this is why you should stay in school
kids because well the application is the
advancement of your own life the other
thing the other thing the reason why you
should say in school so you don't end up
like Donald Trump here listen in this in
this tape he commits two crimes as far
as this National Security information is
concerned okay there's two of them the
one is the actual document itself and
they keep saying oh but it could be
newspapers but the other crime is he
tells the person who does not have a
clearance about this document he cannot
he cannot disclose lows that this
document exists right okay that is a
crime okay it doesn't matter if he's if
he's pointing at a stack of newspapers
or not he cannot tell these people that
this document even exists you dumb
[__] get stop talking about how
oh well there may or may not been the
media is doing this [__] this morning
like oh there may be knockments may not
who knows the audio tape there's no
video It Doesn't The Details Matter
right well he does tell you but it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter because
he can't tell the people in the room
that this document exists
he knows that he [__] says that like
Texas Paul says which I will say might
go to the theory that Donald Trump knew
that this recording existed because this
is the document that oh oh wow missing
here's the thing here's the thing that
reason why Donald Trump knows this is
recorded or this recording is this
because he recorded it listen to it here
it is you can hear it right now how
close he is to the [__] microphone
listen to his voice and listen to how
far the other voices are away listen
this is a bad sick people but that was
your cue you know against you what
started right at the time when Millie's
talking about oh you're gonna try to
they were trying to do that before you
even were sworn in okay so a lot of
people are wanting to know who the
staffer is I don't know who it is yet I
don't know there's confirmation but if
you listen to these voices on this
recording you can tell the recorder is
sitting closer to Donald Trump than it
is to his staffer it's not like the
staffers like you know what I should
record this conversation just in case
just in case Donald Trump tries to go
south on me here maybe you would think
oh well maybe it's the writer in the
room who's holding the recorder let me
put your mind at ease for that because
listen listen when the writer starts
talking that's right trying to overthrow
your life well with Millie uh let me see
that I'll show you an example he said
that I wanted to attack Iran
isn't it amazing I have a big pile of
papers this thing just came up look
I have a big pile of papers if you've
ever seen this [__] desk if you ever
see this [__] desk he always has a
big [__] pile of papers like this I'm
surprised that people would ever be able
to find something on there I mean like
you know they're like oh man people
people who are highly intelligent or
have this are typically disorganized and
I'll agree man I got stuff on my desk
but I'm not going out here claiming I'm
some [__] stable genius when I'm
actually a [__] idiot like Donald
Trump but the other thing is that this
is and when that when the tape was you
know the transcript was released
everyone's like well how did this tape
come to be and then we learned that Mark
Meadows had negotiated a deal and it
turns out
that the audio recording that comes from
the July 21st interview that Trump gave
was part of a memoir for Mark Meadows so
this was someone who was working on the
Memoir for Mark Meadows and Donald Trump
was like Hey this Memoir yeah that's
cool but focus on me and that's how I
actually take it I actually believe that
the recording was intended to be like
hey why don't you tell me about your
time work with Mark Meadows what was it
like as the chief of staff and blah blah
all this stuff right
but I think what happened was Donald
Trump was like ooh someone wants to come
and interview me well I've got the
perfect thing to show how important I
really am and he used that opportunity
to show these documents and show these
papers and reveal this classified
documents of people who were not given
that type of access
and showed it to them and was like oh
this is my opportunity opportunity as an
ego [__]
maniacal person in egotistical someone
who's a sociopath a narcissistic [__]
this is his moment to say yeah Mark
Meadows is cool but like check this [__]
out and that's what I honestly think
happened is because it was scheduled and
it was an interview he took it as an
opportunity to brag about himself
on behalf of this interview Memoir for
Mark Meadows you know what else Texas
Paul I believe that Donald Trump there
was several recording devices in that
room because not only did the person
writing the Memoir about Mark Meadows
when a recording Donald Trump wanted a
recording of it too I believe that and I
believe that that I I think we're gonna
this idiot released this [__] copy of
this recording and I think that it's his
copy not the copy that Jack Smith has
but maybe I'm wrong Maybe I'm Wrong
let's listen to the rest of it see if
you can tell with the writer this was
him
they presented me this is off the Record
but they presented me this this was him
this was the defense department in him
wow we looked at some this was him this
wasn't done by me this was him all sorts
of stuff pages long
wait a minute let's see here
yeah I just found isn't that amazing
this totally wins my case you know
except it is like highly kind of
eventually oh what wait what was that
what was that he said he said oh I'm
sorry wait what was that what he did
there though you have to remember he
says this is off the Record which again
he knows it isn't it it is it it is an
interview and he said again this is off
the record and then within just a few
moments goes oh yeah this is
confidential yeah it's high the kid's
top secret [__] don't report on it
don't show anyone this recording okay
right
I tell you one thing that's not being
reported on here that this this actually
does confirm Mark Meadows cooperation
because think about it if you're the doj
if you're Jack Smith you have no
knowledge this exists
you know you don't have ESP you don't
know this interview happened
you don't that came from Mark Meadows
and his people and they they told the
doj yeah there's an interview here where
he says it on tape
yeah I mean Mark Meadows just burned
Donald Trump to the ground oh yeah he
did do you think do you think Mark
Meadows set up Donald Trump with this
interview
now I don't think he set it up but I do
know he he it he knew it occurred and he
knew there was a confession on that tape
and I think there's you're going to see
a lot more that Jack Smith has that we
don't know he has because Mark Meadows
you know the entire time Mark Meadows
would just sit there with his head down
just punching away on his phone you know
you know he was making notes that dumb
son of a [__] just said
that yeah you think he actually typed
that dumb sumbitch like like on his
phone like that was his notes you know
like I you know I would be shocked if
there weren't expletives in there if you
had to work with Donald Trump I mean if
you had to work with Donald I would be
surprised if you didn't have nicknames
for him like [__] or you know I mean
just well you know what you know what
the doj having a key a key okay you hear
the word [__] the [__] people
there that's Donald Trump yeah check the
key what I don't wanna what I want to
know because
when the first when the transcript came
out right uh you know I said that was
that was pre-indictment that was yeah
that was pre-indictment it got released
and then they write it I think there was
like a day or two and then the
indictment had came to be sure to be
sure Jack Smith did not leak any of this
stuff yeah there's no way
and also
why would you ever in your right mind
leak something that's a [__] Smoking
Gun of some guy saying hey I know that
you're recording me and I know that you
don't have classifications or that you
haven't been given uh the the access for
this type of stuff but I'm going to say
on the well off the Record but on the
tape that this is classified oh this
look I don't also know what
case he was talking about I'm still
trying to figure that out from 20. well
he's talking about it go ahead go ahead
go ahead
what he's talking about on that
recording is the attack on Iran this
these are the documents that are
involving the attack on Iran what cases
it's Mark Miller's job as the joint
Chief of Staff to go to the president
and say we have this situation we have
Iran involved in this situation here are
your options sir boom and he gives them
to him Donald Trump took took that
classified information that that spelled
out as much as they would tell Donald
Trump because they they stopped telling
him everything
I can only imagine why Texas fall they
would not tell him all the classified
information he took that [__] stuffed it
into a box with this dirty golf shorts
and and and took it to Mar-A-Lago
like Gabe was saying his fragile
freaking ego they were doing the
interview they were talking about oh
well this was a coup against you they
were setting you up to something he says
yeah look at this recommendation from
Mark milley to attack Iran this wasn't
my idea they said I wanted to attack
Iran this was Mark milley he wanted to
do this no you dumbass that's his job
I don't think there's actual court case
he's just saying that he he's making his
case is this like the is this like a
public public uh right
I was like what Donald Trump versus
versus reality I guess right because I
was like what was happening publicly in
July of 2021 that we knew about right
because I I know I know what Texas Paul
is saying like what was happening during
the time of when these papers well
because Mark Milly's like he was a
[__] idiot the guy the guy actually
took seriously a plan to attack Iran
which is not a serious thing you're not
a serious person if you're considering
that and Mark mellow didn't say it in so
many words but he alluded to it and
Donald Trump was mad that Mark milley
basically called Donald Trump stupid uh
for considering attack and Iran now the
question remains rather Donald Trump
told everybody I want you
I want you to uh
I want you to
get me plans on how to attack Iran and
then Mark Millie's like what what and
he's like yes I don't want you to do got
it got it okay so that's what was in the
news cycle got it okay I was trying to
figure this out yeah so Texas Paul just
gave us a New Yorker article that says
uh letter from the Biden's Washington it
says you're gonna have a [__] War
Mark milley's fight to stop Trump from
striking Iran
um okay so this I so the Assumption here
is that this was gonna help
the public opinion I think is what he's
trying to say when he says right hey so
the public opinion against Donald Trump
to say no no no no no I'm not the one
who did this it was actually Mark Miller
okay okay right I'm not the idiot he is
even though I'm actually an idiot let me
show you some more of this idiot listen
in listening
look at this information
and Hillary would print that out
yeah did you hear what he just said
there this is secret information right a
stack of newspapers is not secret
information yeah right that is public
information you know so this whole right
wing spin about oh he point he was
pointing a newspapers this isn't really
no he tells you right here this is the
freaking briefing you know I mean this
is Mark Miller's briefing to me he
wanted to do this well and it's probably
a briefing that Donald Trump ordered
right he's like get me a plan to attack
Iran and Mark boom is like that's not a
thing and he's like I don't care I want
it to be a thing and Mark Bowie's like
but it's not but I want it to be get me
it now and also Diet Coke and I'm not
[__] you that happens in this [__]
video are in this audio this happens it
happens watch watch it's great look at
this you attack and Hillary would print
that out all the time you know
or Anthony Weiner by the way
yeah I was just saying because we were
talking about it and you know he said he
wanted to attack Iran
this was done by the military given to
me
um
here it is listen see this President I
couldn't be closer yeah no I can't you
know but this is yeah this is still a
secret I can't declassify it because I'm
not the president anymore meaning it's
not it is a secret and it wasn't he
knows how it works right right exactly
it's [__] wild [__] it's wild [__]
and and the other thing too is so we
have to remember that
that this
uh this came out this tape was revealed
that it was late well in May it was
revealed that as of late 2022 so
December 2022 is when this tape was
brought into possession and so we also
have to remember or keep in mind that in
in that uh in that time frame right
that that is at least
uh the earliest that we know that Mark
Meadows and or other associates who were
involved have been cooperating with Jack
Smith so you know it didn't come out
until five five to six months after the
fact of of that team working with Jack
Smith
to be giving them this one tape but
here's the thing too
if there's one tape there are several
tapes right there you can never be oh
this is just a piece of this tape this
is just this is just one of the tapes
that they were like look we're gonna put
in the indictment
in the in the event that this does leak
because I'm sure that Jack Smith team
also has a bunch of contingency plans to
say like you were saying they put it in
there for a reason there's a ton of
conversations and text messages that we
know where the listed in the indictment
which a lot of trump people because they
either can't read or unwilling to read
don't know that these things were
actually said you're not going to put
something in an indictment if you don't
have the actual evidence to back that
[__] up and so they know that Donald
Trump has it and so they say well fine
you want to play a game let's play a
[__] game if I have this and I say I
have this and you leak it
I want to make sure that I'm protected
because it's not going to come up with
something of oh they made it up it's all
[__] it's all fake it's AI this and
that no I'm gonna list it out because we
have the actual evidence and if you try
to I don't know throw it out there and
cause some sort of nullification of the
evidence or the jury because you've
tainted the evidence pool now
I want to make sure that people know
that it existed before it gets out there
right well let's finish this up because
we're running over time but this part
right here where he describes
yeah he describes it as far as it brings
up Hillary Clinton oh yeah did they find
classified documents where didn't they
find Clash of my with the clintons they
didn't find them with the clintons they
didn't find them with the Obamas
yeah hey yeah well let's let's see how
he describes this the one word he uses
to describe it it's it's wild
is that interesting yeah it's so cool I
mean it's so it's so cool so cool and
you probably almost didn't believe me
but now you believe me no I believe it's
incredible right yeah they bring some
bring some Cokes in please
yeah
he he turns to Walt his Coke conspirator
says bring some Cokes in please man and
that that is Donald Trump being like
yeah see like it was totally friendly we
had Cokes it was just a normal meeting I
was just talking casually off the Record
like Donald Trump thinks when you say
this is off the Record that it can't be
used in a court case as evidence against
you
he's great he's got some great uh legal
logic he gets it all from Tom the gang
where's the tiny shirt listen this tape
is damning but like like Gabe said like
Texas Paul says this isn't the only
piece of evidence they just knew that
this piece of evidence Donald Trump
would leak it and I believe that I think
that's why I think that's why it's in
the indictment I think they didn't
originally want this in the indictment
but they leaked the transcript before
the indictment which they only did Jack
Smith a favor by doing that by going to
the media and saying hey this is going
to be a damning piece of evidence
because it's a Smoking Gun tape so we'll
go ahead and leak it ahead of time and
then Jack Smith can't use it he's like
[__] I won't [__] around find out [__]
he puts it in the indictment which makes
it part of the material evidence of the
case which means it doesn't matter if
Donald Trump releases the tape or not or
leaks it and then blames it on Jack
Smith it doesn't [__] matter it
doesn't matter don't listen to right
Wingers when they tell you stupid [__]
like this oh he was just pointing to
classified information because folks
there's two crimes on this [__] tape
two of them one of them he's showing
people classifying information and he's
got clapping classified information
where he shouldn't have it
the second crime is he's letting someone
who does not have a clearance know that
this exists that this document exists he
cannot do that that is not something you
can do he knows it he says it in the
[__] tape in the audio so don't
let him [__] fool you don't let him
confuse you you go after him you
continue to push you [__] get serious
about this [__] because this guy's a
[__] traitor he's a goddamn traitor
and he's a traitor who who I can't even
I can't even [__] tell you he was
Texas ball I think he was actually
trying to impress the woman because the
writer's a woman he was trying to
impress her she's a woman she's got a
pair of tits and he's like I'm gonna
impress her and I'm gonna show her
because remember yeah this is not the
only person that was in the room it was
the it was the writer this reporter or
whoever the uh for the Memoir and then
also a person that was
um
uh
uh a member of his pack
right so there's there's at least two
people that are in the room at the time
of recording this uh and then possibly
while NADA if he you know was there well
he was there until he needed to go get
the cokes right I need to go get the
Cokes and you hit it right on the head
Gabe it's just fragility I mean you
cannot ask Donald Trump hey Donald Trump
tell me what you think about old Tony
Michaels without it turning into let's
talk about Donald Trump right I mean
that's you know I can't wait I cannot
wait for another one of Mario spaces I
just want to wait for the one that comes
in I'm sure there'll be one today well
they do have one but it's about Russia
yeah of course will you guys do me a
favor yeah the next time you go into one
of those spaces because you you always
hear kim.com talk about Tony bobolinski
I mean I hate the way he says bubalinski
all the time
just ask him where all that evidence
from Tony bobolinski That was supposed
to be coming out two years ago yeah
we'll ask you where is it it's never
come can you can can you get that
information he'll be in the Russia space
tonight because he's a Russian sick of
fan he's one of Putin's puppets he also
loves Nazi all right propaganda he does
which means he loves Nazis he does he
does he does kim.com is a photo there's
a photo of kim.com wearing a Nazi helmet
people can Google it you can see it
online it's not made up it's not fake
News Right the dude is like well I like
it that's a propaganda what do you
[__] butter it Harlan Hitler first
and then yeah
that dude's got a head bigger than that
man oh my God oh my God Texas Paul's got
a custom order his cowboy hats but
kim.com has to custom order his Nazi
helmets Jesus Christ what a day on the
show we went over time everyone make
sure to check out Texas Paul at
realtexaspaul.com the link is down below
in the description Texas ball give us
your Shameless plug about your show
tomorrow
catch me tomorrow 10 a.m we'll do it we
will we're gonna talk a lot all things
Russia Tomorrow there's oh Russia Russia
Russia Russia okay yeah we're definitely
going to talk Russia
weird nobody's heard from pagosan since
he disappeared imagine that you think
he's dead
I know I think he's still in a room
sweating his ass off signing off
documents
over to Putin oh okay but as soon as he
signs that last line he's a goner huh
well that that could be I progression's
an [__] I I wouldn't I would not be
uh shed a tear at pregosian um ate an
ammo sandwich either the same with Putin
uh so catch Texas Paul tomorrow Russia
Russia Russia everything Gabe Sanchez do
you have what was that coming yeah I've
got what was that on uh Marjorie Taylor
green Lauren bobert I got another one on
Marjorie Taylor green thinking that
people are spying on her through her TV
uh I've got uh probably one of these
chips but I've got another one I'm
blanking on so I'm gonna try and you
know I'm trying to work on them and
great and get him out quicker excellent
I want to let the audience know next
week is Patriot week it's Patriot month
next month this is pride month but next
most Patriot month so next week is the
Fourth of July I know I know you'll
probably be celebrating with your family
your friends having a great weekend a
holiday weekend we're going to take off
for the show Monday Tuesday Wednesday we
will not be on the air so this the the
the third the four 4th and the fifth we
will be off so we're going to take a
little bit of a reprieve a little bit of
a break so we appreciate you and we want
you have a great holiday weekend so I
want to give you that announcement
um and again same time same place
tomorrow don't forget do not forget to
subscribe here on the Tony Michaels
podcast on the YouTube channel don't
forget to go download this some [__]
you're definitely going to want to
download and listen to the audio version
it's very important Apple Spotify even
better come listen over there that's
right come watch it come watch you can
watch it on YouTube you can also watch
it on Facebook if you don't know that on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels go follow
us over there on Facebook also you can
watch it on Twitch it's free to follow
us on Twitch twitch.com the Tony
Michaels I appreciate everyone who's
resubscribed today with your Amazon
Prime account don't forget to do that as
well if you if you've linked your Prime
account to your Twitch account and you
subscribe to us to give us that free
couple bucks every month don't forget to
resubscribe Texas Paul thanks for
joining us Gabe Sanchez I'm glad you're
here for taco Tuesday we didn't get to
talk tacos maybe we'll talk tacos
tomorrow
that's it wacky Taco Wednesday same time
same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon
look here I want to tell y'all something
I've been thinking about this whole
Hunter Biden thing all right first of
all I don't think he needs to be
president anymore let's get that out of
the way first off
but this whole thing with him as a
constitution
Republican as a fiscal
fiscal physical as a physical
conservative Constitution Republican
bald eagle
machine gun alpha male Republican
I was really against
um Hunter Biden because I saw
some of his videos and he's got a his
peckers the size of a PBR tall boy
and and I was like that's too big and
then he's like having tons of sex like
the guy gets laid all the time I'm like
nobody needs to have a pecker that big
or get laid that much and so I was mad
I was mad mostly about that but then
also because people were telling me I
should be mad and I wasn't 100 sure why
but I knew that I should and I think
Donald Trump maybe told me I should so I
was mad and I'm still mad I guess but
then I just heard the thing that they
got him as far as breaking a law he had
a gun he wasn't supposed to have and he
was trying to not pay taxes
and now I'm like well I mean
sounds all right to me that's kind of
that's kind of my thing is not having
guns and not paying taxes you know what
I mean like this Hunter by hand that big
old pecker and uh all that sex I mean
this I think this guy might be an alpha
thank you